the paranoid are those who survive okay
if you don't think that there is some
sort of goal to have some sort of
digital passport some sort of tracking
system involved you're not paying
attention okay if you don't think that
there's some sort of social score coming
our way that is already in effect in
china you're not paying attention okay
and if you don't think that this is an
obedience test if you don't think
especially after that episode that pat
put up yesterday with what we know that
the moderators are doing behind the
scenes at these major social media
conglomerates then guys you are just not
paying attention and to your point as
far as us being around us not not to get
off topic merrick garland who was
nominated to be a supreme court justice
united states and is now in the biden
administration
essentially just weaponized the fbi to
go after anybody okay who has had any
sort of opposition to critical race
theory and education all right he sent a
memorandum to the fbi asking them
specifically to treat opposition to
critical race theory and um
quote-unquote vaccine hesitancy okay
which which you know
is this this broad term for questioning
anything that's official narrative okay
they're treating people that disagree
with
our elected
you know administration
as political dissidents
that is this that is the very precipice
of the slippery slope all right we
already knew we already know that obama
weaponized the irs that is not up for
debate that's not a conspiracy that was
confirmed that should have been one of
the biggest conspiracies since nixon
everybody knows it happened nobody cares
for some reason he weaponized the irs
against his political opponents now his
vice president's administration
is
publicly weaponizing the fbi against
political opponents
that's a problem that is a slippery
slope okay so while i understand and i
agree we're not north korea we're not
iran i think that we can become it so
much quicker than anybody gives any sort
of credence to
i i hear your point i i i also think
you're right on being paranoid and i
appreciate you saying well you know it
could happen it could happen
in my humble opinion i've just seen what
true tyranny looks like pat came from
iran i think it's hyperbolic to even
assume we're anywhere even close to it
bro that's just my point okay again i
just tried to tell comedy and i couldn't
do it inside of a city no you chose to
do a secret show you could have done it
in and i could donna hughes i could not
absolutely not
absolutely not i could not have
i would i would have they they would
have made it it was actually illegal for
me to earn money
we just talked about the new york
restaurants
or a freaking mandate for something that
you have 99 chance of
surviving i mean what the hell are we
doing what are we talking about right
now and at the end of the day what is
the definition of being an american
this country was formed well you can
actually come here and what's great is
that we actually have like these
debates or whatever we want to call it
but we can walk out of here and still be
cool yeah we respect each other's
opinion and stuff like that like they
want to take it away yeah they want to
take it away by force they don't want
you to speak at what point if you live
in new york city do you say enough's
enough i mean if you're like dude many
are saying it exactly many are so that's
the beauty of living in america again is
saying you know what yeah moving to
florida or i'm going here i'm going
there for now so adam let me ask you
you know
one day you're gonna have a family right
that's the plan one day you'd like to
have a family one day by your choice
we're not gonna force you i just want
you know don't force it yeah we're not
gonna tell you go
we're gonna be i've almost you know i've
been forced into marriage before it
didn't work out it's not a good strategy
yeah we like choice but if you're open
to arranged marriage i like i wouldn't
mind doing the arranged marriage i got
some people anyways
so yeah let's go back to it you get
married you have kids okay god willing
yeah god willing that happens you have
kids okay
your level of uh paranoia will change
i'm sure when you have kids yeah let me
explain to you how it works like
uh
senna looks at me and she gives me these
eyes and she goes like this
and she kind of goes like this with her
hair and she takes these pictures
and all i think about is oh my gosh some
guy's going to go crazy over there
how the hell am i going to fight off
that guy you know what cinna did the
other day
so somebody said something to sent on
school you know what she said to the kid
she said
you know my brother's big and strong and
he will punch you in the face
i assume he's talking about billy yeah
he doesn't go read a book
he's worried about zenna
he's gonna have two six foot five
brothers and a dad with a million dollar
car what do you possibly do to impress
that girl and big ass uncles yeah that's
right can you imagine so i said i sat
there i'm like
by the way honestly like for a moment i
was not in the conversation everyone's
talking i disappear i'm in la la land
and this la la land is her boyfriend and
i'm like what's going to happen 15 years
down the road so he comes from tommy by
the way she's 15 so she could very
easily and she's doing cheer right now
she's singing a cheer the other day of
her school i'm like oh my gosh she's
pretty she puts the stuff on and she
does the spike she's 15 she's five but
she'll be 15 in no time
what just happened but what i'm saying
what i'm saying to you is ten years down
the road you think that then i think
about dylan i think about tico like i'm
doing a parent-teacher conference
my level of paranoia for that is higher
today than when i was 29 years old when
i was 27 my paranoia was less the moment
i got married paranoia increases because
of a different lens
then you have the first kid your wife's
pregnant second then you have different
paranoia then you have your age you know
parents age all of that stuff adds up i
think the biggest thing is when a person
who lacks any paranoia that something
catastrophic can happen to this country
you you you will get caught and when you
get caught it's not going to be fun
because
sometimes in life
almost you know in your mind you're like
i can fix any problem i can fix any
issue i'm good i can fix this okay
there's certain problems you can't fix
you have cancer you can't fix cancer
there's certain problems you cannot fix
and there's different forms of cancer
one form of cancer is health the other
form of cancer is when it gets into
politics politicians and the other form
of cancer is when these politicians are
able to get into universities and
schools and then they get to the kids
the side effects of overcoming that
cancer is 40 years yeah it's not two
years bro generation it's 40 cuba is
still effed up till today how many
decades has it been one cancer goes in
iran
1978 79 that cancer is still there
43 years later and nobody can do nothing
good about it and iran signs a contract
with china for 24 years for 400 billion
whatever the number is that cancer is
going to be there for another 25 years
that's sev that's 70 years of a cancer
so
there needs to be pushback there needs
to be i can think for myself there needs
to be let me think about it there needs
to be let me get back to you there needs
to be that notion to the government the
government needs to be held a little bit
more accountable and not like hey you
don't answer what i do in my life i
appreciate the feedback thank you for
doing your job so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you